THANK YOU, JEFF.
MORE TO COME IN A MOMENT.
>> WHY ARE WE HAVING THIS
CRISIS AT THE BORDER?
WHEN JOE BIDEN GOT ELECTED THE
FIRST THING HE DID WAS STOP
CONSTRUCTION OF THE BORDER WALL.
REINSTITUTED CATCH AND RELEASE
AND ENDED THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY A VERY SUCCESSFUL
FOREIGN POLICY ACCOMPLISHMENT
WHERE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAD NEGOTIATED WITH MEXICO THAT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA WOULD REMAIN IN MEXICO
WHILE THEIR ASYLUM PROCEEDINGS
WERE MOVING FORWARD.
>> Dana: TED CRUZ ADDRESSING
THE BORDER CHRISTS LAST HOUR.
OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS 12 PEOPLE
ENTERED HIS PROPERTY JUST
YESTERDAY.
NINE OF THEM WERE
CONFRONTATIONAL AND FEARS FOR
THE SAFETY OF HIS FAMILY.
THIS RANCHER JOINS US NOW.
SET IS SCENE.
WHAT HAS IT BEEN LIKE?
>> A LOT DIFFERENT THAN I’VE
EVER SEEN IT.
I’VE BEEN HERE 25 YEARS AND SO
I’VE SEEN UNDER MANY
ADMINISTRATIONS I’VE SEEN LOTS
OF TROUBLE.
BUT I’VE NEVER SEEN IT AT THIS
LEVEL AND I’VE NEVER SEEN IT
WITH THIS QUALITY OF PEOPLE.
THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE COMING
THROUGH THAT REALLY ARE COMING
TO BETTER THEMSELVES AND BETTER
THEIR LIVES BUT I THINK THE
DYNAMICS HAVE CHANGED OF THAT
TODAY.
IT IS NOT THE SAME GROUP OF
FOLKS THAT I’M USED TO SEEING.
>> Bill: WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
THAT, JOHN?
WHAT’S THE DIFFERENCE?
>> WELL, THEY ARE MORE
CONFRONTATIONAL.
THEY HAVE SOMETHING TO LOSE.
I DON’T KNOW IF IT’S BECAUSE OF
HUMAN SMUGGLING.
MY PROBLEM IS I’M 40 MILES FROM
THE BORDER SO IT’S NOT LIKE I’M
SITTING ON THE EDGE OF THE
BORDER AND ALL THESE PEOPLE ARE
COMING ACROSS THE RIVER TO ME.
THE ONLY REASON I CAN ATTRIBUTE
MY PROBLEMS GETTING BIGGER AND
BIGGER EVERY DAY IS THE VALUE
OF HUMAN SMUGGLING.
WITH THAT SAID, I AM RIGHT
BEFORE THE CHECKPOINT ON U.S.
90 SO THE SMUGGLERS ARE
BRINGING THEM HERE, DROPPING
THEM OFF AND THEY’RE COMING
THROUGH MY PROPERTY.
THAT IN TURN HAS CAUSED LOTS OF
HEARTACHE FOR US.
NOT TO MENTION TEARING DOWN OUR
FENCES.
COMING TO OUR HOUSES AT NIGHT.
I HAVE A DAUGHTER.
I WON’T LET WALK ON THE
DRIVEWAY, YOU KNOW, TO JOG OR
EXERCISE BECAUSE OF THIS
WITHOUT HAVING A DOG WITH HER.
YOU KNOW, WE’RE KIND OF BEING
LEFT DOWN HERE AND THE BORDER
PATROL’S HANDS ARE TIED.
THEY ARE WORKING TO KEEP
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS UNDER
CONTROL IN A FACILITY.
THEY AREN’T OUT HERE IN THE
FIELD WHEN I NEED THEM.
THEY CAN’T COME BECAUSE THEY’RE
SO STRETCHED OUT.
THEY GOT -- WE’RE OVERWHELMED.
WE’VE BEEN THROWN TO THE WOLVES
HERE AS FAR AS I’M CONCERNED.
>> Dana: IS THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS YOU ARE SPEAKING OUT
TODAY AND COMING ON TELEVISION?
AS A RANCHER YOU PROBABLY LIKE
TO KEEP TO YOURSELF, GET YOUR
WORK DONE AND HAVE A GOOD LIFE
THERE WITH YOUR FAMILY.
YOU DECIDED TO COME ON
TELEVISION TODAY WHY?
>> WELL, I’VE BEEN WATCHING THE
MEDIA JUST AS EVERYONE ELSE HAS.
IT IS PORTRAYING A WAY
DIFFERENT PICTURE THAN WHAT
WE’RE HAVING.
WE’RE SEEING THINGS OF PEOPLE
TOURING FACILITIES THAT LOOK
LIKE EVERYTHING IS IN ORDER SO
ON AND SO FORTH.
THAT’S NOT THE CASE.
IF THTHEY REALLY WANT TO SEE
WHAT’S GOING ON AND WHAT THEY
DON’T WANT TO SEE, THEN THEY
NEED TO COME VISIT PEOPLE LIKE
ME THAT HAVE TO BATTLE THIS
EVERY DAY IN THEIR OWN BACKYARD.
THE THING THAT EVERYBODY NEEDS
TO UNDERSTAND, THESE PEOPLE
AREN’T STAYING HERE.
THEY ARE COMING TO YOUR TOWN.
WHETHER THEY ARE GOOD OR BAD
THEY’RE COMING TO YOUR TOWN.
WE HAVE TOO MUCH BORDER PATROL
PRESENCE HERE.
THEY DON’T WANT TO BE HERE.
THEY CAN’T LEGALLY BE HERE.
WE CAN’T LEGALLY WORK THEM.
SO WITHOUT A GUEST WORKER
PROGRAM THAT WORKS, WHERE ARE
WE GOING WITH THIS, GUYS?
>> Bill: WHAT IS YOUR LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE NOW THAT KAMALA
HARRIS HAS BEEN PUT IN CHARGE
OF THIS NATIONAL CRISIS?
>> I HAVE VERY LITTLE
CONFIDENCE IN ANYTHING THAT
WE’RE DOING RIGHT NOW.
AT LEAST IN THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION WE HAD A PLAN.
WE HAD SOMETHING IN PLACE THAT
WAS AT LEAST CONTROLLING THE
ISSUE AND THEY KNEW WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN TO THE
INDIVIDUAL ONCE THEY WERE
APPREHENDED.
NOW WE HAVE NO PLAN.
WE HAVE NO DIRECTION.
WHERE ARE WE GOING?
I DON’T THINK ANYBODY KNOWS
THAT ANSWER.
DO YOU GUYS?
>> Dana: NO, SIR.
>> Bill: NOT TODAY.
>> Dana: JOHN, TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF RESPECT FOR YOU.
WE WOULD LOVE TO KEEP IN TOUCH
WITH YOU, PLEASE.
>> Bill: YOU MAKE SOME
EXCELLENT POINTS.
THANKS FOR SHARING THEM WITH
OUR AUDIENCE AND PERHAPS
POLITICAL LEADERS IN CHARGE AS
WELL.